right today i'd like to talk to you
about the reynolds number
the reynolds number is named after
osborne reynolds who was a british
physicist or fluid mechanics
scientist
and he was did experiments in manchester
on flow of water through pipes
and he discovered that the way in which
the water flowed depended on the size of
the pipe the diameter of the pipe and
and the speed of the water
and he characterized this these
different types of flow in terms of a
number a number that's dimensionless it
doesn't it's just a plain number it
doesn't have kilograms or meters per
second in it or anything like that it's
just a plain number
so i've got a pipe here this is the kind
of pipe that
osbourne rentals would have used and you
can see this has got a a diameter so he
was using pipes like this and passing
water through it and he also to look at
the way the water was flowing in detail
introduced ink through a tiny jet
and he discovered that at low flow rates
uh the ink jet just remained a perfect
if you inject it at the center of the
tube at this end the water's flowing
through then the inkjet remained a
perfectly nice narrow line but when the
water was flowing above a certain
velocity if she called it critical
velocity then the
flow became turbulent
so what we do is we take the velocity of
the flow
and the
diameter or
more more usually the radius of the pipe
and so we end up with an expression
looking like this so the reynolds number
not to confuse it with other symbols
like resistance we normally use re
that's just equal to
the
velocity of flow of the water in the
tube
multiplied by
the
radius of the tube and then divided by
and this is the tricky bit the viscosity
of the water all fluids have a certain
amount of viscosity water is a fluid
it's got a viscosity and the kinematic
viscosity of water is an easy number to
remember it's one divided by a million
or ten to the minus six as we say as
physicists and air has actually when you
take into account the fact that that
air's got a lower density than water uh
that has actually got a higher kinematic
viscosity
the viscosity of air is about one
divided by a hundred thousand
engineers fluid engineers need to know
about the nature of the flow of water in
pipes and around bends for that matter
all of that's very important to them
because it tells them how much water
they can get get get through the pipe
the other place it comes in of course is
is anything that moves through air when
objects like cars or aeroplanes or ships
flow through fluids they set up behind
them
vortices and when
the flow is fast enough the objects are
big enough they they set a big turb
turbulent wakes behind them and
inside those vortices and turbulent
wakes the water is all churning around
and what's happening then is that the
engine that's propelling the boat or the
airplane or whatever the energy of the
fuel of that
is is actually being converted into this
into this turbulence one of the one of
there's a beautiful illustration of
vortex pairs being formed of a nasa
photograph it's a it's a volcano
this this thing was photographed from
satellite with uh a a wind
just a westerly wind flowing over it and
you can see a beautiful
trail of vortices from behind this
volcano
and
these vortices
form it tend to form in pairs one of the
vortices is going around in an
anti-clockwise direction to you and the
other one is going around in a clockwise
direction
to you so these things are called vortex
anti-vortex pairs and they were first
studied in detail by a hungarian or
german scientist called von carmen and
these things are called one calm and
vortex streets because they like houses
on opposite side going
down the street
now that is a truly huge reynolds number
so not only are we forming
pairs of autism in this case we've got
quite a lot of turbulent air in those
vortices in and around those vortices
and we see the vortices in those in that
particular picture very beautifully
because the cloud patterns are picking
up this circular motion the clockwise
anti-clockwise motion of the airflow
inside the vortices so that's one of the
biggest reynolds numbers you can you can
see on earth
now you can get bigger reynolds numbers
than that if you look at the great red
spot of jupiter for example
the great red spot of jupiter's got a
radius comparable with the earth so much
bigger than the volcano and the wind
speeds on jupiter are much higher as
well
a few years ago we had a couple of good
students really good students doing this
project
it was called fun with flat fluids and
this is an experiment that you can do i
picked it up on the web website of
martin rutgers and he's what he's doing
his experiment is he's forming a soap
film and then as the water is flowing
vertically down the soap film what
julian is doing is putting in a tiny
obstacle something a few millimeters
across into the flow and then you can
see the video of the vortice street
forming behind the object
you